Now here's the really really way to think about. Are you more likely to use
situational attributions, or dispositional attributions? That is, are you more
likely to think that the person is responsible for what happens, or the
situation? Well, as it turns out, different situations call for different types
of attribution. For example, when evaluating our own behaviour, whether we
succeed or fail might influence what kind of attributions we use. For example,
say we did really poorly on a biology test, we might blame the fact that a
professor was horrible or we didn't know what was going to be on the test, or
that the test was poorly written. On the other hand, say we got an A on a
statistic exam, we might attribute this good grade to the fact that we're
really smart or we're really good at statistics. So the attributions we use may
depend on the situation.